♪ ♪
- Ahh!
- Oh! My! God!
Oh, my God, you hit my friend,
you frickin' psycho!
- I'm so sorry.
I feel like I had stopped.
- No, it wasn't.
You were still coming back
like an idiot.
- [groans]
I'm huwt!
- He just came out of nowhere.
- Yeah, tell that
to your cellmate, man.
- My head huwts.
- Shh, come on--
why are you talking like that?
[both giggle]
- C-come closer.
I think these might be
his last words, maybe.
- [groans]
On a scale of one to ten,
how happy are you
with the service at Doner?
- What?
- I think he said,
on a scale of one to ten,
how happy are you with
your service over at Doner?
- I don't get any service,
I work there.
- Work there?
God damn it.
- What kind of scam is this?
- I wasted, like,
ten blood capsules on you.
I keep on swallowing them.
- Don't waste people's time,
sir.
- You should be
ashamed of yourself.
- Don't just eat
the blood capsules.
Are you just swallowing them?
- Yeah.
- I use these all the time.